Guten Abend.
Mein Name ist Ustolari. Ich bin Arstin auf dieser Station.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegüchbeführen. Ist das okay für Sie?
Das ist in Ordnung, ja.
Okay. Ich werde erst Ihre Personische Daten aufnehmen.
Dann komme ich gleich zu Iran abtöllen und besparen.
Wie heißt es Ihnen?
Ich heiße Marianne Bachmann.
Marianne Bachmann.
Mit B.
Okay. Frau Bachmann.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 54 Jahre alt.
54.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 25. Mai 1968.
Ah, 166.
Okay.
Wie viel wiegen Sie zur Zeit?
67 Kilo.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,66 m.
Ah, gut.
Frau Bachmann, wie kann ich Ihnen halten?
Was für Beschwerde haben Sie?
Ja, ich habe so seit gut einem Tag seit gestern
habe ich Schmerzen im Bauch.
Und habe auch Öbelkeit.
Aber ich habe noch nicht erbrochen.
Und ich habe auch etwas Fieber.
Fieber.
Seit wann haben Sie Fieber, seit gestern?
Ja.
Haben Sie das Fieber gemessen?
Im Mund.
Ja, 38,7.
Das war das zweite Moment am Mund.
Okay.
Sie haben erwähnt, dass Sie Bauchschmerzen haben.
Ist das links- oder rechts- oder in der Mitte?
Ein bisschen mehr rechts.
Okay.
Wie beschreiben Sie diese Schmerzen?
Sind Sie hier dumpf?
Oder stetschend?
Ja, sind mehr so dumpf, drückend?
Ja.
Aber ich möchte nicht gerne da irgendwie Gewicht drauf haben.
Ein schweres Betttuch oder ein Kissen.
Das ist mir zu schwer dann auf dem Bauch.
Okay.
Und haben Sie eine Ausstrahlung bemerkt?
In irgendwelchen Körper?
Ein vielleicht so ein bisschen in den Rücken, aber nicht viel.
Rechten.
Ja, in den Rücken.
Aber es ist oben im Bauch auf der rechten Seite, da am Rippenbogen.
Okay.
Gestern, was haben Sie gegessen?
Gestern habe ich Nudeln gegessen.
Vor dieser Bescheide.
Nudeln habe ich gegessen und etwas Tomatensoße.
Aber nachmittags habe ich noch auf einem Geburtstag ein Stück Sahnetorte gegessen.
Okay.
Wie beschreiben Sie diese Schmerzen?
Auf einer Schmerzkala wobei ein Zehler ist, aber 10 Zehltag ist.
Wie bewerten Sie es?
Ja.
Zwischen 6 und 8.
6 oder 8.
Sind die Schmerzen immer da oder gehen Sie wieder weg?
Nein, die sind eigentlich immer da.
Okay.
Haben Sie solche Bescheide schon einmal gehabt oder?
Ja, vielleicht so vor zwei Monaten.
Da hatte ich auch Bauchschmerzen, auch rechts, aber nicht so stark.
Und ich hatte damals auch keinen Schmerz.
Okay.
Was haben Sie damals gemacht?
Waren Sie bei Ihrem Arzt oder?
Nein, ich habe einfach mal nur einen Tag lang gar nichts gegessen.
Nur etwas bunken.
Und dann wurde es auch wieder etwas besser.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme bei dem Stuhlgang?
Nein, normalerweise nicht. Nein, das geht.
Alles gut.
Wie oft gehen Sie auf die Toilette?
Einmal am Tag.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme mit dem Wasserlassen?
Nein.
Wasser kann ich nicht halten.
Ich brauche auch nachts nicht auf Toilette.
Nein, da habe ich keine Beschwerden.
Ich habe auch noch nie große Probleme gehabt.
Okay.
Haben Sie Appetit oder Verlust?
Seit gestern nicht.
Sonst habe ich guten Appetit und kann auch sonst normal alles ganz gut essen.
Aber seit gestern habe ich keinen Hunger.
Okay.
Seit gestern, Sie haben keinen Appetit.
Sie haben einen Gewicht verloren oder zugenommen?
Nein, mein Gewicht habe ich ganz gut gehalten in den letzten Jahren.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen schwindelig?
Nein.
Okay.
Wie ist Ihre Schlaf?
Normalerweise ist mein Schlaf gut.
Aber in der letzten Nacht konnte ich nicht so gut schlafen.
Weil es schmerzt.
Okay.
Haben Sie Sortgerennen?
Nein.
Okay.
Oder volle Gefühl?
Ja, jetzt, seit gestern, da ist das alles so hoch.
Ob Luft auch beim Bauch ist.
Okay.
Was haben Sie dagegen eingenommen?
Das Medikament?
Nein, bis jetzt nicht.
Aber nachdem es heute Morgen nicht besser wurde, habe ich mir gesagt,
jetzt muss ich doch mal zum Krankenhausen mich untersuchen lassen.
Ja, Sie haben gut gemacht.
Okay.
Leiden Sie ein bisschen für die Erkrankungen, Frau Obama?
Was verstehen Sie unter Vorerkrankungen?
Ja, ich meinte zum Beispiel Schilddrösenunterfunktion,
Blutzuckerkrankheit, Bluthochlöse.
Ja, Schilddrösenunterfunktion habe ich.
Seit meiner Pubertät, da habe ich eine Schilddrösenunterfunktion
und muss auch ein Medikament einnehmen.
Okay, seit wann haben Sie gesagt?
Ja, seit der Pubertät, vielleicht seitdem ich
14, 15 Lebensjahr.
Okay.
Was nehmen Sie?
Ja, Ältroxin 50, nämlich einmal eine
und eine Iotablette.
Eine Iotablette, okay.
Was noch gibt es für Erkrankungen?
Manchmal im Frühsommer habe ich heute
Schnupfen, manchmal dabei Asthma.
Asthma.
Wenn das so ist, das ist so höchstens aber
vier bis fünf Wochen im Jahr, dann nehme ich auch
bei Bedarf einen Asthma-Speich.
Aber nur in dieser Zeit.
Okay.
Ich möchte Sie
sagen, dass ich den Namen des Spray habe.
Zalbutamol.
Zihabun Hoeschnupfun.
Diese allergie oysart such Asthma.
Asthma und Nase läuft
und die Augen tränen.
Hoeschnupfun, wahrscheinlich gegen
Gräser und gegen Birken, Birkenpollen.
Gräser.
Also, in der Zeit, wo die Gräser
abends bis zu sechs Wochen im Mai,
vielleicht zu Ende April, Anfang Mai,
aber im Juni ist das meist vorbei.
Okay.
Frau Baumann, rauchen Sie?
50 Geräten am Tag rauche ich.
Seit wann ist es so?
Seit circa 20 Jahren.
Okay.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, ich trinke hin und wieder mal ein Glas Wein.
Aber das ist nicht viel.
Pro Woche vielleicht drei Gläser pro Woche.
Okay.
Und bitte nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht persönlich.
Das ist eine Routinefrage.
Halben Sie Erfahrung mit Drogen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Frau Baumann, ich habe noch einige
Fragen über Ihre Familiengeschichte.
Eltern leben noch, Vater mutter.
Die Eltern leben noch, der Vater
ist 84 Jahre alt.
Und er hat hohen Blutdruck.
Mutter ist 81 Jahre alt,
die hat Alterszucker.
Und sie hat Gallensteine gehabt,
dann ist daran operiert worden.
Gallenstein.
Hatten Sie schon einmal
internistische Untersuchungen?
Ich meinte,
einen Barculturell wurde ihnen durchgeführt?
Nein, da kann ich mich nicht dran erinnern.
Okay.
Sind Sie in Leicester-Seit im Ausland?
Nein, ich war vor circa einem Jahr
war ich mal für zwei Wochen auf Mallorca.
Das war vor einem Jahr.
Vor einem Jahr, okay.
Ich war vor einem Jahr in der
Corona-Krise.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Frau Baumann, gegen Corona?
Ja, ich hatte 3 Impfungen.
Ich hatte aber auch Corona schon im März.
Aber das war gut verlaufen.
Das war nicht schlimm.
Vielen Dank.
Frau Baumann,
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Verwaltungsangestellte
und arbeite in einem Büro.
Okay.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet,
ohne mit meinem Mann zusammen.
Okay.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, ich bin 30 Jahre alt.
27 Jahre und 24 Jahre.
27 Jahre.
Haben Sie Stress in der Arbeit?
Nein.
Ich habe keine Angst.
Ich möchte Sie etwas ergänzen.
Ich habe es besucht.
Meine Schwester, die ist vor einem Jahr
an der Geilenblase operiert worden.
Sie hatte keinen Stein.
Sie hat auch keinen Stein.
Ich war da, ich war operiert worden.
Ich weiß, dass du auch keinen Stein hast.
Aber ich weiß es nicht.
Ja, Maria Baumann.
Wir sind zu Ende.
Wir haben alle Informationen
in den Gesamt.
Jetzt werde ich Sie für Parisch untersuchen
und Glutab nehmen.
Und einen Ultraschallduschwürre.
Ein Gerlänchstein.
Aber wissen Sie,
dafür brauchen wir wenig Zeit.
Ein wenig Zeit.
Bitte nehmen Sie Platz.
Ich komme gleich.
Darf ich noch etwas essen, wenn ich Hunger haben sollte?
Nein, bitte essen Sie nicht.
Aber nach der Untersuchung,
wenn es eine Gerlänchstein ist,
dann können wir die Stationär aufnehmen.
Oder eine Infektion.
Okay?
Ja, okay.
Okay.
Ich habe ein paar Fragen.
Aber ich habe Kollegen andere Fragen.
Erstmal,
eine genokologische Anämnese.
Haben Sie regelmäßig menstruationen?
Nicht mehr so richtig regelmäßig.
Nein, mein Diagnokologin sagt,
ich wäre jetzt in den Wechseljahren.
Ich habe eine genokologische Anämnese.
Ich bin jetzt in den Wechseljahren.
Wie viele Jahre?
Im Klimakterium.
Vorab sind Sie einmal operiert worden.
Sind Sie einmal operiert worden?
Ja, ich bin schon mehrfach operiert worden.
Als Kind.
am Blindam und am Leistenbruch. Leistenbruch? Ja. Leistenbruch, ich muss überlegen, war rechts.
Gibt es 500 für die Schmerzen?
Nein, ich habe die Schmerzen ja erst seit gestern.
Nach dem Essen? Ja, ich habe ja Mittags, habe ich ja Spaghetti gegessen, Pasta und Tomatensoße
und nachmittags noch auf einem Geburtstag eine Sahne bruchen.
Vielleicht hingen das damit zusammen, ich weiß es nicht genau.
Sie haben gesagt, dass die früheren Ähnliche beschwerden haben.
Vor zwei Monaten.
Wie waren diese früheren Ähnliche beschwerden, zum Beispiel in Besuch auf Dauerholtigkeit,
schwere Grad und Auslösung?
Nee, die waren nicht so stark und ich hatte glaube ich auch kein Fieber und kein Schüttelfrass.
Aber es tat schon weh, aber es war nicht so stark wie jetzt.
Okay. Das war alles meine Frage.
Okay. Haben Kollegen andere Fragen?
Letzte Frage. Haben Sie am Anfang Einmalstuhlgang gehen oder gehen Wind ab?
Ich hatte heute Morgen auch noch etwas Stuhlgang.
Also vor drei Stunden hatte ich auch noch mal etwas Stuhlgang.
Ist die Haut oder Augen Veränderungen bemerkt?
Nein, keine Farbveränderungen.
Meine Schwester, als sie operiert werden musste, wurde die etwas gelb.
Da war irgend ein Stein, glaube ich, im, wie heißt das, Gallengang oder so etwas.
Und da musste sie dann operiert werden. Aber die war etwas, dann etwas gelb geworden.
Meine Schwester, nicht ich.
Können wir anfangen?
Ja.
Guten Abend.
Herr Oberarzt, ich habe heute eine neue Patientin aufgenommen.
Ich würde gerne Ihnen ihr vorstellen. Hätten Sie dafür gesagt?
Ich würde die Patientin Ihnen gerne vorstellen. Ja, habe ich gesagt, ja.
Es handelt sich um Marienne Bachmann. Sie ist 54 Jahre alt, sie ist 60 schwer, 1 Meter...
Kilogramm schwer?
Kilogramm schwer und 1 Meter, 6 und 60 groß.
Er kam heute wegen Zeit gestern, 5. Handler, Epigasik.
Sie kam. Sie kam heute wegen Zeit gestern, 5. Handler, Bumfer, Durukhander.
Sie kam heute wegen Zeit, 5. Handler, Bumfer, Berash.
und voll der Gefühl, Meteorismus vorliegen.
Ja. Sind die Beschwerden rechts oder links im Oberbauch?
Rechteitig.
Rechteitig, okay.
Ja, sie gab an Kriegsi zu haben.
Sie hat gestern sein Fieber 38,7 gemessen.
Und sie hat gestern etwas Fett gegessen.
Und vor der Beschwerde, dann die hat diese Schmerzen.
Auch sie klackt Uba in Somnia und in Appetanz seit gestern.
Okay.
Ja.
Wann war der letzte Stuhlgang?
Heute Morgen.
Okay, gut.
Ja, sie berichtet das sie ein bisschen für zwei Monate gehabt haben.
Aber alle Beschwerden, zahlen spontan, färschwommen.
Okay.
Hat die Patientin jetzt Schmerzen genommen?
Nein.
Sie hat nichts, ein Genomen.
Sie ist erst zu uns gekommen.
Okay, gibt es eine auffällige Familienanamnese?
Ja.
Okay.
Ja, also beide, bei Mutter und bei Schwester,
wurde eine Julizistektomie vorgenommen.
Hat positive Familien gestern.
Ja.
Okay.
Gut, gibt es sonst aus der Anamnese noch etwas zu berichten,
Voroperationen im Bauch?
Ja.
Anvor Erkrankungen leidet sie Hypothrose seit 15.
Und dagegen nimmt sie Trockstein, fünfmal Mikrogramm,
morgens und eine Iot-Tablet.
Okay.
Sie hat allergieche Asthma,
Besonderes Abmay, Bissum, Juni.
Also, ein saisonales Asthma.
Ja, saisonales Asthma.
Auch neben dieser Asthma leidet sie allergieche,
Birkenfolen und Greza-Allergie.
Diese ist durch Rheinitis und Konjunktivitis.
Okay.
Gibt es Voroperationen?
Ja, sie hat ausgehend Tonselektomie,
Appendektomie gehabt.
Auch restzeitige, sie hat restzeitige,
in den neuen Herne-Operation gehabt.
Ja, Herne-Otomie.
Herne-Otomie gehabt, ja.
Herne-Otomie, rechtseitige Herne-Otomie.
Gut. Was ist Ihre Verdachtdiagnose?
Ja, meine Verdachtdiagnose ist Acutecholistitis.
Ja.
Ich werde erst die Korprallischen unterzucken.
Ich erwarte beide Korprallische Unterzuckungen
eine restzeitige Subkostal-Sturk-Schmerz.
Okay.
Das heißt Morphysation.
Ich bin für die
Verkaufung der Sonografie.
Ich werde die Sonografie über die
Blutop-Name über die
Blutop-Pilz, Blutpengen,
Kechwindikarp,
Saap,
Kolestas-Parameter,
Leber-Parameter,
Bilirubin,
auch Nieren-Parameter,
und dann eine Abdominalsono-Würde.
Okay.
Ja.
Und die Patientin muss auf alle Fälle nicht dann bleiben?
Unbedingt.
Sie muss dann bleiben, ja.
Gibt es noch differenzialdiagnostische
Überlegungen?
Ja.
Als differenzialdiagnostisch
kam Ulcus Venticuli, Ulcus Dodini,
Piollonephritis in Betracht.
Ja.
Eventuell beginnende Pancreatitis.
Pancreatitis auch.
Sie hat epigastrische Schmerzen.
Muss ich auch eine EKG schreiben
um eine mögliche Herzprobleme
aus Socialistinien?
Ja.
Ich denke, Sie haben da die
differenzialdiagnostischen Überlegungen
komplett gemacht.
Alles gut?
Ja.
Und Sie haben auch, finde ich,
die Anamese systematisch erhoben.
Allerdings haben Sie die vergessen,
die Anamese-Operationen zu fragen.
Das hat dann der Kollege gemacht.
Und die Familienanamese haben Sie nur gemacht,
Vater und Mutter.
Und nicht nach Geschwistern gefragt.
Dann wäre die Schwester mit ins Spiel gekommen.
Und die Schwester wurde ja auch an der geilen Blase operiert.
Also, da muss man auch nur daran denken,
dass die Familienanamese möglichst,
nicht nur die Eltern,
sondern auch berücksichtigt.
Ja.
Dann denke ich,
bei der Vorstellung beim Oberarzt,
die medizinischen gewünschten,
medizinischen Fachbegriffe,
finde ich sehr gut referiert,
sehr gut mitgeteilt.
Und ja, ich finde, das war gut.
Sie haben sich nicht aus der Ruhe bringen lassen.
Im Anfang haben Sie, ich mache es mal vor,
haben Sie so berichtet und gesagt,
das haben Sie nachher nicht mehr gemacht.
Da achten Sie darauf,
dass Sie möglichst nicht so machen.
Das wirkt besser.
Okay.
Jetzt den Kopf raus.
Ja.
Es sind Angewohnheiten, das glaube ich auch.